معنى من ادريس ابا كرامتي الباحث والمحلل
السياسي ومن القاهره عطيه عيسوي الخبير في
شؤون الافريقيه في جريده الاهرام
نبدا مع تديسي
سيد تديسي الا يحق لمصر
ان تدافع عن وجودها الذي يمثل
نهر النيل ومياه النيل تمثل اصل هذا
الوجود الا يحق لها ان تدافع عن ذلك
هل يمكن نعم تقول تقول اثيوبي او بالاحرى
اثيوبيا ترفض تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
المصري لكن مصر الا يحق لها ان تدافع عن
وجودها المتمثل بنهر النيل ومياه نهر
النيل وحصتها في
اعتقد ان المفارقه تكمل هنا مثل ما لمصر
مصالحها وهي تعبر عنها المره الاخرى
لاثيوبيا ايضا مصالحها
الطبيعيه والتي ترتبط
بالنهر ولهذا السبب
اثيوبيا لاهميه قصوى
للنهر النيل كما تفعلوا مصر تماما لهذا
السبب من منظور الشخصي انا ارى انه مفهوم
لمصر عن
صالحها لكن التصريحات الاستفزازيه لا
ينبغي ان تعتبر تعبيرا عن المصالح
والحقوق لانها سوف تؤدي الى ظروف سيئه
وهذا من مصلحه المنطقه ككل
سيد عيسوي
اديس ابابا تدعو الى الحوار والى حل ازمه
سد النهضه
بالحوار والاتفاق في حين ان مصر
كما يقول ضيفنا من اديس ابا تعتمد اللغه
الاستفزازيه لماذا لا يكون اللجوء الى
الحوار بدل توتير
الاوضاع على خلفيه السد
اولا هذا ليس ليس هذه ليست تصريحات
استفزازيه هي تذكير للعالم وللمهتمين
بالامن والسلام في المنطقه بان لمصر حقا
يجب الحفاظ عليه في مياه النيل الذي تعتمد
عليه بنسبه 97% لانها ليست لديها مورد اخر
للمياه العذبه
ثانيا مصر اعلنت مرارا استعدادها للتوصل
الى اتفاق والاستئناف المفاوضات اذا توفرت
الاراده السياسيه من الطرف الاخر وهو
اثيوبيا لحتى الان
المفاوضات تدور في حلقه مفرمه وتصل الى
طريق مسدود في كل مره بسبب رفض اثيوبيا كل
الاقتراحات التي تم تقديمها سواء من مصر
او من السودان او من اداره من الاداره
الامريكيه في عهد الرئيس السابق
وكما تعلم هناك اتفاق او شبه اتفاق تم
بنسبه 90% ولم يتبقى سوى عشره بالمئه
ورفضت اثيوبيا التوقيع المبدئي عليه بينما
وقعت مصر عليه طبعا مصر لا يمكن ان توافق
على شيء سوى التوصل الى اتفاق قانوني ملزم
يلزم كل الاطراف بتنفيذه وليس مجرد
اجراءات ارشاديه كما تريد اثيوبيا لاداره
مياه النهر واداره بغير ذلك لا اظن انه
يمكن التوصل الى اتفاق سيد تاتسي استمعت
الى ضيفنا من القاهره وسؤال المطروح هنا
طيب
كيف يمكن لادرس ان تدعو الى حوار
وهي
لا تتوصل او بالاحرى ترفض الاتفاقات وفي
نفس الوقت وصلت الى التعبئه الرابعه يعني
هي تريد ان تستفيد من الوقت ان تضيع الوقت
من اجل ان تعبئ كما تريد السد ثم تدعو الى
الى الحوار على الملا
مهمه اود ان
اكررها وهي قوله ان المفاوضات تدور في
حلقه مفرغه هذا صحيح لكن السبب الذي اورده
ليس صحيحا هذه الحلقه المفرغه ترجع في
المسؤوليه فيها على كل الاطراف
الذين يريدون الى المحافظه على الوضع
الراهن وخاصه المصريين الذين يتمسكون
بالوضع الراحه منذ فتره طويله بالطبع 90%
من الاتفاق تم التوصل اليه لكن العشره في
المئه الباقيه ما تزالت تشكل تحديا لماذا
هذه نقطه مهمه
مثلما لمصر بوعف قلقها اثيوبيا لديها ايضا
باعت
ومصالحها لكنها مع ذلك تنخرط بشكل فعال من
خلال منصه الاتحاد الافريقي
وتتفاوضوا بحسن النيه في عمليه الحوار
والتصريحات الاخيره
هي حقيقه
العبثيه ولا تضيف اي قيمه لعمليه التوصل
جهود نعم
سيدي عيسى العشره بالمئه تتحمل مسؤولياتها
المسؤولياتها مصر وليس اديس ابابا كما
يقول ضيفنا الاثيوبي
لا لا لا هذا هذا غير صحيح تماما لان مصر
عرضت
اقتراحات كثيره رفضتها اثيوبيا منها على
سبيل المثال انها تضمن اقتراح يضمن
لاثيوبيا تشغيل سد النهضه لانتاج الكهرباء
بنسبه 80% من طاقته في حاله اسوا حالات
الجفاف ومع ذلك رفضت اثيوبيا المساله يعني
واضحه تماما كيف العلاقات بين الدول كما
تعلم لا تقوم على حسن النيه ولا على
العلاقات الشخصيه تقوم على اتفاقيات يتم
احترامها من قبل كل الاطراف بدون هذا
الاتفاق القانوني الملزم الذي يتضمن اليه
الفصل في الخلاف عند تنفيذه اذا تم التوصل
اليه زائد ضمان
مرور المياه بقدر كافي لا يعرض امن مصر
المائي ولا امن السوداني المائي
للخطر
خلال فتره الجفاف والجفاف الممتد بدون ذلك
لا يمكن ابدا ان يكون هناك يعني اتفاق
عادل ثانيا ان مصر اعترفت بالسد واعترفت
بحطه اثيوبيا في التنميه وفي انتاج
الكهرباء واثيوبيا لا تريد الاعتراف بحق
مصر في المياه اللازمه شكرا لعاشت شعبها
عطيه عيسوي من القاهره الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه في جريده الاهرام وشكرا لضيفنا
من اديس ابابا كرام تاتسي الباحث والمحلل
السياسي